>> Aright. I'm really, I'm really in to this
dashboard thing. We've got our, our nice pretty visualized data.
>> Awesome.
>> I suspect that there is a way in Sales Force to,
kind of, get this functionality, you know, filtering data, things like
that, but in the app itself. And, like. I could imagine
maybe, there's someone at the festival whose, whose job is to organize
the electronic music bands, or the Bossanova bands for you, and that,
that person might want to just look at bands of a specific genre.
>> Yep.
>> Is there a way to filter data like that.
>> Yeah. So, that's actually a pretty easy functionality to create.
>> Okay.
>> let's take a look here. So what we're
looking at right now is a List View of
just the recent bands. That's what comes up by
default. And if you click that Go button, it's going to
take us to the All list view. So
that's showing us all the bands completely. But like
you saw from that little pick list, the only
option we have is All. So, in order to
create a view to sort by genre, we have
to create a new view. So click that Create
New View Link. And so this is going to create
a list view of any filter that we define.
>> Actually going to do it Bossanova bands.
>>
[LAUGH]
That's a small list.
>> It is a small list. Select a banner. All bands.
>> You want All Bands and then we want to choose a genre field. And
then equals whatever, and so you could make
these pretty complicated with filters on like dates
and this date but also this name and this genre and get really specific. Like
if we have multiple festivals, it could even
be genres but only at a certain festival.
>>
Mhm. Okay. And so I'm going to, let's see I'm going to
show the band name and I'm going to show the manager
phone number and maybe I want to know their Twitter handle
so I can Tweet them in all my PR stuff.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'll make it visible to all users.
>> Sounds good.
>> Hit Save. Anyway, with this set, there are only three Bossanova bands, so,
this manager does not have a lot of work to do, but that's okay.
>>
[LAUGH]
So I really like where we're going with
this. You know, we can really visualize our data
and get a feel of what it would be like to use the app on the day of.
>> Yeah. So I want to think more about
that because, I mean, having this visualization is nice.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But it's actually, it's not that clear to me what
I would actually be doing on the actual day of the festival.
>> Right. And you know, we haven't completely added functionality
into it yet, even. Right now it's just static data and
it's showing us information, but it's a little bit of calculation
based off the formulas that we've made, but we haven't added
too much human interaction pieces to it, you know, that actually.
>> Yeah.
>> Streamline processes.
>> Okay, so, can we do that?
>> Yeah, let's do that.
>> Cool.